well first of all we've been waiting for
this for a long time it's been quite
controversial there's been lots of leaks
lots of rumors going around Westminster
so first of all let me take you through
some of the names that are on this list
so peerages first of all Sean Bailey now
if you remember Sean Paley uh ran to be
the mayor of London in 2021 there's also
Ben gascoigne he was a very close aide
for a number of years in lots of
different roles to Boris Johnson he was
part of the vote leave campaign his
leadership election
Etc Ben Houchin the mayor of uh uh
t-side who is currently
a little bit in the spotlight because of
issues around the governance of T side
and in particular something called T's
works well separately from that he has
been nominated for a period Ross
kempsell another close aide to Boris
Johnson Charlotte owing
um she I think he's a a surprising name
on this list for a period because she's
quite young she has worked the number 10
policy unit but has only had um a few
jobs in Westminster one of those was
working for Boris Johnson of course
she's on the list uh colvia ranga and
Dan Rosenfield as well knighthoods
um Connor Burns is a Johnson loyalist MP
Simon Clark
um there are others Michael fabricant
Jacob Reese MOG will get a Knighthood I
think one of the interesting things
clearly about this list is we were
expecting some names
um of MPS as well including and we know
that in the last hour
um Nadine Doris has stood down now she
was rumored to be set for a period on
this list we heard from her in an
interview and the suggestion I think was
that she something had gone on behind
the scenes that made her think she was
no longer uh able to go into the Lords
for whatever reason now she has stood
down with immediate effect triggering a
by-election and we don't know exactly
what's happened behind the scenes there
but there were other MPS that we were
expecting
um to be named for periods today
um Alex Sharma Nigel Adams Aleister Jack
none of those names appear
um to be on this list now we have had as
well a statement from the prime
minister's press secretary so this has
just come in as is convention the Prime
Minister forwarded the former prime
minister's periods listerholak unaltered
holak holak I should say is the House of
Lords committee that vets and approves
the prime ministers on honors list
it says holak then passed back their
approval list the prime minister then
accepted holux approved list and
forwarded unamended to The Sovereign for
their approval he had no involvement or
input into the approved list it is a
point of fact that it is made public by
the commission if a prime minister
overrules the commission's advice okay
so this is number 10 in a statement uh
potentially in response to Nadine
Doris's interview in which she seemed to
be hinting that the Prime Minister might
have tried to interfere with this list
what number 10 are saying is that there
is a a formal process it goes between
the house of laws committee to number 10
the prime minister in their words
forwards it to The Sovereign for that
approval and what they are saying
basically in this statement is look the
Prime Minister hasn't interfered with
this list but quite a few interesting
names I think on here and we'll be
picking through this to find out who
else is on this list I can see I can see
a few over here sorry all this
information has just been coming in I
can see that there are other things that
have been awarded Dame's commander of
the order of the British Empire so this
is an Obe uh to pretty Patel Andrea
Jenkins will also get one of those as
well CBS gutoh Harry who you might
remember is a former director of
communications at Downing Street there's
other names on this as well Jack Doyle a
former director of communications at
Downing Street if you remember he
resigned during partygate so lots of
interesting names I haven't been able to
read through them all yet but I think
the interesting thing here the peerages
who has got them who hasn't of course
there was speculation the Prime Minister
would be handing out periods to
potentially his dad even his sister it
looks like that
hasn't happened in the end as I say a
statement from number 10 strongly
putting forward the case that the Prime
Minister has not been interfering behind
the scenes at all with this list but it
just it does seem to be slimmed down and
of course we saw in the last hour that
certain Nadine Doris has resigned and I
think that's probably something to do
with what's happened in the last few
hours in relation to the pages